aunque la cifra de contagios diarios
sigue cayendo y de manera consecutiva
hoy el país registró un poco más de
20.000 nuevos casos 13.000 menos que
hace exactamente una semana la situación
sigue siendo muy delicada al menos 37
mil personas siguen hospitalizadas por
kobe hoy que el país alcanzó la muy
triste cifra de 100.000 personas muertas
por el cob y se preguntan los expertos
si está fallando la estrategia del
gobierno y además los tiempos en los que
adopta esta medida inicialmente en marzo
2020 cuando arrancó la pandemia
fuertemente aquí en el reino unido- los
expertos preveían proyectaban que habría
20.000 muertes
la estrategia dicen algunos está
fallando porque ha habido tres
confinamientos de hecho inglaterra está
en uno desde hace varias semanas las
fronteras siguen abiertas las
mascarillas no son obligatorias y no se
respeta la distancia social y las
autoridades hasta el momento
adoptando medidas más estrictas para
evitar que la población siga
interactuando tan cercanamente también
se asegura que las medidas se han
adoptado muy tarde el primer
confinamiento se decretó a partir del 23
de marzo de 2020 cuando algunos países
europeos habían adoptado esa misma
decisión varias semanas antes